สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพุธค่ะวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่
8 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วัน
อังคารอืวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 7 เดือน
อะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ 25
566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วัน
พฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 9 เดือน
อะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้เวลา 15
น 15 นกี่นาที 0
นาทีก็คือ 15 นตรง 15:00 นตรง
ค่ะ 1500 น 0 นท
ครูฟ้านะคะได้ค่ะครูฟ้าเป็นคนเก่งมาก
เรื่องบอกเวลาหรือเปล่าคะ่า 3  0 นอันนี้
เป็นความเก่งของครูฟ้าหรือเปล่าอืครูฟ้า
เก่งเหรอคะบอก
เวลานักเรียนบอกว่าเอ่อไม่ต้องเก่งก็ได้
นะดูที่นาฬิกาใช่มั้ยนาฬิกาเนี่ยมีเข็ม
สั้นแล้วก็มีเข็มยาวใช่มั้ยคะอันนี้อะไร
เนี่ย 12  3  6  6
9 ใช่ไหมอ่านักเรียนบอกเอออันนี้ไม่ต้อง
เก่งก็ได้นะดูเวลาอือ้าแต่ครูฟ้าเไม่ได้
ดูที่นาฬิกานะคะนักเรียนเดูที่ดวงอาทิตย์
ใช่ค่ะก็บอกเวลาครูหญิงถูกเก่งนะถูใช่ค่ะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะ
IQ  3
390 มันยไปมั้ยครูฟ้า EQ
2 ป้า EQ ก็เยอะไปมยคะ
อ้า
เออใช่มยถ้าเราเนี่ยมี IQ มากๆเราก็เก่ง
แต่มันก็ไม่ต้องก็ได้นะเพราะว่าอย่าง
ไอสไตล์เนี่ยไสตล์เ้ามี IQ เท่าไหร่นะ 180
ม 180 หรือเปล่า
อไม่รู้นะคะอย่างอัลเบิร์ตไอสไตน์อบตเค้า
เนี่ยไอคดีไอคเยอะใช่มั้ยคะฉลาดอ่าเคก็
เก่งเค้าเก่งอะไรนะเคมีมั้ยเคมีใช่ฟิสิกส
ไม่ใช่ฟิสิกสเคมีค่ะิกเคมีใช่มยเาคิดคิด
นิวเคลียร์ระเบิดตู้มอะไรของเขาอ่ะนะคะ
เออแต่ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าหรือว่านักเรียน
เนี่ยไม่ต้องเก่งเท่ากับไอสไตน์ก็ได้เอ้า
จริงหรอเอ้าเรื่องธรรมดาๆดเราก็เก่งได้
ครูหญิงอ่ะครูหญิงนี่ค่ะครูหญิงครูฟ้า
หรือว่านักเรียนเนี่ยก็เก่งไม่เหมือนกัน
ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเก่งภาษาไทย
เอ่อถ้าครูหญิงครูครูฟ้าแล้วก็นัก
เรียนนักเรียนนักเรียนครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าก็
เก่งภาษาไทยนักเรียนคิดออืแต่ถ้าูหญิงครู
ฟ้าแล้วก็คนไทยคนไทยคนไทยเรา 2 คนเก่ง
หรอก็เก่งนะเหรออ้าครูฟทำไมคุณหยุด
ชคูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะกับคนไทยเนี่ยครูฟ้าไม่
เก่งภาษาได้มั้ยใช่ใช่ค่ะจริงๆครูหญิงกับ
ครูฟ้าก็ไม่ได้เก่งภาษาไทยเนาว่าเราเป็น
ครูสอนแบบอวาดรูปให้นักเรียนดูไงเแต่นัก
เรียนอาจจะคิดว่าออ้ครูหญิงครูฟ้าเก่ง
ภาษาไทยอือก็ขอบคุณนะคะอืจริงๆก็คือเรา
เก่งใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าเรายังมีเรื่องอื่นๆที่
เก่งอีกเรื่องธรรมดาๆดครูหญิงก่อนนะคะได้
ค่ะครูหญิงครูหญิงเก่งอะไรคะครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ครูหญิงวาดอะไรคะครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะ
เต็นท์เต็นท์มันต้องแบบนี้ไงอันนี้คือ
เต็นท์อันนี้คือ
เต็นท์นี่เต็นท์อันนี้ไม่ใช่เต็นท์อออ
แล้วแล้วครูหญิงวาดอะไรนี่ไงครูฟ้าอะไร
ที่มันต้องเป็นลักษณะเป็นสามเหลี่ยมแบบ
นี้ล่าแล้วก็มีปลั๊กด้วย
อืแล้วก็
ร้อนก็
คือเต่ารีดค่ะครูฟ้าผู้หญิงแปลว่าเก่งเตา
ีใช่เดี๋ยวแปลว่าผู้หญิงเนี่ยวาดรูปเนี่ย
ไม่เก่งและไม่ใช่คววามเก่งของครูหญิงและ
ครูหญิงวาดรูปแล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่เข้าใจ
ไม่ใช่ครูหญิงไม่ได้เก่งเตารีดค่ะครูฟ้า
แต่เตารีดเนี่ยเอาไว้ทำอะไรเตารีดก็ต้อง
เอาไว้
รีดผ้าสิคะใช่ไหมเวลาเรามี
เสื้อหรือว่ามีกางเกงที่เราซักเสร็จแล้ว
เนี่ยแล้วมันแบบยับใช่มยมันมีรอยยับอ่า
เนี่ยเสื้อยับเราก็เอาเตารีดเนี่ยมารีด
ครูหญิงเนี่ยเก่งรีดผ้าค่ะครูฟ้าครูหญิง
คิดว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยเป็นคนที่รีดผ้าเก่ง
อืผู้หญิงรีดก็จะมีใช่ค่ะอันนี้ก็จะเป็น
โต๊ะใช่มยโต๊ะรีด
ผ้าเอตรงดีก็จะเป็นเป็นที่ที่เราเนี่ยเอา
เตารีดมาวางแล้วก็เอาเสื้อใส่ลง
ไปอแล้วเราก็รีดนะครูหญิงคิดว่าครูหญิง
เนี่ยรีดผ้าเก่ง 1
ชมงผู้หญิงเนี่ยรีดเสื้อเชิตอันนี้เป็น
เสื้อเชิตมั้ยเนี่ยเนี่ยเสื้อเชิตได้แบบ
มากกว่า 10 ตัวค่ะครูฟ้าเอ๊ะทุกคนก็ทำได้
มั้ยครูพก็ทำได้ค่ะครูหญิง 1 ชั่วโมงมาก
กว่า 10 ตัวนะไปแต่เรียบนะครูหญิงเป็นคน
รีดครูหญิงคิดเองไงว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยรีดผ้า
เก่งอืครูฟ้ารีดผ้าเก่งมั้ยครูฟ้ารีดผ้า
เก่งค่ะอืเพราะครูฟ้าเคยรีดผ้าให้พี่ชาย
นะคะครูฟ้าค่ะอันนี้พี่ชายนะคะแล้วก็อัน
นี้ครูฟ้า
ค่ะ
ฟ้าแล้วก็พี่ชายค่ะรู้แล้วค่ะแล้วูฟ้า
รีดผ้าให้พี่ชายแล้วพี่ชายบอกไว่าฟ้าฟ้า
เนี่ยรีดผ้าดีมากรีดเรียบมากเวลาดูนี่แบบ
ว้าวพี่ชายเนี่ยนะคะไม่ได้บอก
อ้าวแต่พี่ชายเนี่ยให้เงินครูฟ้าพี่ชาย
บอกว่าฟ้าถ้าฟ้ารีดผ้าให้พี่ชายพี่ชายจะ
ให้เงินครูฟ้า 1,000 บาท
โอทุกครั้งครูฟ้าก็เคยรีดผ้าเก่งหรือ
เปล่าไม่รู้แต่ได้เงินใช่ค่ะอันนี้อันนี้
ครูฟ้าอาจจะชอบนะคะเก่งหรือไม่เก่งไม่รู้
แต่ครูฟ้าคิดว่าครูฟ้าเก่งอะไรอ่ะครูหญิง
รบก่อนนะคะนี้คือครูหญิงเก่งเก่งแบบ
ธรรมดาเห็นมยเก่งแบบธรรมดา
้อไม่ต้องเหมือนไอสไตล์ไง
อะไรคะครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็วาดรูปน่าจะไม่เก่ง
แล้วล่ะค่ะนะคะนักเรียนรู้มยคะว่าคือ
อะไรสี่เหลี่ยมค่ะมันก็
คือ
หนังสืออ่านหนังสือเก่งไม่ใช่เฮ้ยครูฟ้า
คือครูหญิงพูดคือหนังสือนะคะนักเรียน
กล่องเหรอ
คะูอ้าซัก
ผ้าใช่ค่ะเครื่องซักผ้าใช่มั้ย
ใช่คะเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวๆๆอะไรครูฟ้าครูฟ้าใช้
เครื่องซักผ้าซักผ้าแล้วครูฟ้าจะซักผ้า
เก่งได้ยังไงอ่ะเอ้าซักผ้าเก่งได้แต่ครู
ฟ้าใช้เครื่องซักผ้าซักไงครูฟ้าไม่ได้ใช้
มือครูฟ้า
ซาก้านักเรียนคะไม่ใช่ว่าทุกคนซักผ้าแล้ว
หอมนะคะ
โอครูฟ้าเนี่ยซักผ้าแล้วเวลาเอามาดมหอม
เสื้อครูหญิงก็หอมเสื้อครูฟ้าก็หอมค่ะเ้า
ูฟ้าซ่าเก่งค่ะหอมแบบที่ว่ามันมีกลิ่นออก
มาคือเรานั่งอยู่แล้วเราก็ได้กลิ่นน่ะ
อย่างงั้นอ่ะอือออเหมือนครูฟ้ารู้ว่าถ้า
เราเนี่ยมีเสื้อใช่มยมี
กางเกงกี่ตัวครูฟ้าก็ต้องใส่แบบไอ้พวกน้ำ
ยาใช่มั้ยเค้าเรียกน้ำยาซักผ้ามใช่มันจะ
เป็นกลิ่นแบบดอกไม้อย่างเงี้ยใส่น้ำยา
เนี่ยกี่ฝาเอออใช้เวลาเท่าไหร่แล้วผ้า
เนี่ยหอมอครูฟ้าซักผ้าเก่งอืต้องตบมือค่ะ
ครูฟ้าชอบซักผ้าด้วยนะจริงๆมันมีเทคนิคนะ
คะนักเรียนถ้านักเรียนักทำยังไงอ่ะสมมุติ
ซักผ้าใช่มั้ยซักผ้าเสร็จแล้วแล้วก็เอามา
ใส่ตะกร้าเนี่ยนะคะ
ตะกร้าค่ะแล้วก็มีผ้าแล้วก็มีผ้าแล้วก็
ต้องเอาผ้าเนี่ยนะคะนักเรียนเอาไปทำอะไร
คะเอาไปตากแดด
ออเพราะฉะนั้นก็ต้องมีเวลาสิคะว่าเราต้อง
เริ่มซักผ้ากี่โมงเพราะถ้าู้หญิงซักผ้า
1800 น
แดดเนี่ยไม่มีแล้วไงไม่ได้ค่ะไม่ได้เรา
ต้องซักผ้าตอนร้อนๆใช่มยตอนเนี่ยค่ะ
อาทิตย์ร้อนๆนะคะเวลาเที่ยน
อืเที่ยงใช่มยแล้วเราก็ตากผ้า
ค่ะตากผ้านะคะตากผ้าแล้วพอเวลา
ประมาณกี่โมง 17 น
อ๋อทำอะไรคะเก็บผ้าค่ะอือ๋อต้องดูเวลา
ต้องตากประมาณอันนี้ครูฟ้าตากประมาณ 5
ชมงมใช่นเรประเทศไทยร้อนนะคะมันโอเคค่ะ
ใช่ประมาณนั้นถ้าเราตากผ้านานๆผ้ามันจะ
ไม่หอมไงอืต้องเวลาต้องพอดีเออๆๆอันนี้
ต้องใช้ความเก่งนะใช่ค่ะนเอใช่แล้วค่ะมัน
จะทำให้ผ้าเนี่ยเสื้อของเราเนี่ยนะคะ
หอมอืแล้วครูฟ้าเก่งอะไรอีกคะครูหญิงไม่
มีแล้วนะครูหญิงเก่ง 1
อย่างครูหญิงคนเราจะเก่ง 1 อย่างได้ไงครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะนักเรียนครูหญิงให้ครูฟ้า
ก่อนไงเออแล้วเดี๋ยวถึงค่อยครูหญิงครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าเก่งอะไรอีกนอกจากซักผ้าซักผ้าเก่ง
แล้วครูฟ้าทำอะไรเก่งอีก
คะ
ะอันนี้หน้าครูฟ้าหรอใช่ค่ะอันนี้ครูฟ้า
นะยิ้มเก่งมันไม่ได้นะคะครู
ฟ้า
เก่งหะครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะวาดรูปเก่งค่ะอ๋อ
ตอนนี้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยกำลังโชว์สกิลครูฟ้า
กำลังโชว์การวาดรูปอยู่อ่ะแต่ครูฟ้าเขา
วาดรูปเก่งจริงๆนะคะคิดว่านักเรียนเนี่ย
น่าจะเคยเห็นข้างหลังครูฟ้าใช่มั้ยที่จะ
มีรูปของซุปเปอร์สตาร์เอ่อผู้ชายค่ะผู้
ชายอันนี้อะไรคะูฟ้าวาดรูปเก่งคุณหญิง
กำลังดูแล้วก็บอกว่าอะไรคะนักเรียนถาม
หึวาดรูปไงคะนักเรียนวาดรูปอครูฟ้าเนี่ย
วาดรูป
เก่งอืแต่ว่าครูปกติปกติครูฟ้าจะวาดรูปใน
iPad ใช่มครูฟ้าก็จะมี iPad ครูฟ้ามีรูป
ที่ครูฟ้าวาดเนี่ยโชว์ให้นักเรียนดูได้มย
คะได้ค่ะนักเรียนอ้าอื
ว่านักเรียนเห็นรูป 3 รูปที่ครูฟ้าวาดนัก
เรียนอาจจะคิดเอ่อนักเรียนเข้าใจคำว่า
เก่งผิดหรือ
เปล่า
เอวาดรูปเก่งนะคะแต่ว่าช่วงนี้ไม่ค่อยได้
วาดแป๊บนึงนะไม่เป็นไรเออแต่ว่าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยเขาวาดรูปเก่งจริงๆนะคะนัก
เรียนครูหญิงการันตี
ใช่ค่ะอืรูกเยอะอันนี้รูปที่ร่างนะคะอัน
นี้ว่าเอ่อแปบไปมแสงมันนักเรียนบอกไหน
อ่ะให้ดู
อะไร
โหก็ยังนิดนึงนะคะผู้หญิงน่าจะรู้จักเค้า
นะคะว่าดูซีรีส์เค้าวันนี้นะคะแล้ว
ก็รูปที่นักเรียนเห็นบ่อยๆหรือว่าอะไร
อย่างเงี้ย
แต่อนี้มันวาดนานแล้วนะคะนักเรียนครูฟ้า
วาดรูปเยอะอยู่นะคะหลายสไตล์อืแการ์ตูน
อะไรพวกเนี้ยโอรูปนี้ครูฟ้าก็เป็นคนวาด
เองใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะรูปนี้ครูฟ้าก็วาดเอง
นะคะ
อืเห็นมั้ยนักเรียนนักเรียนดูุครูฟ้าคครู
ฟ้าช่วยเปิดไฟด้วยค่ะอ๋อมา
แล้วมันก็จะมืดๆนิดนึงนะคะนักเรียนอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยอืเห็นมนั่นแหละนี้เก่งนะเพราะ
ว่าครูหญิงทำไม่ได้แบบนั้นนะคะนักเรียน
นักเรียนอย่าดูอี 3 อันนี้นะคะอันนี้
เนี่ยมันไม่ได้เป็นให้ครูฟ้าเขทำให้ดูเฉย
ๆว่านี่คือการวาดรูปนะคะครูฟ้าวาดรูปเก่ง
อือันนี้เก่งจริงๆอ่าอันนี้ครูหญิง
การันตีนะคะเก่งแล้วก็นอกจากวาดรูปเก่ง
แล้วนะคะครูหญิงครูฟ้ามีอย่างอื่นเก่งอีก
หรอคะใช่ค่ะอะไรคะอันนี้อะไรคะสี่เหลี่ยม
ยาวๆ
ะมาสเตอรเชฟ
จสิคือเรียกว่ามาสเต CL ครูฟ้าทำอาหาร
เก่งใช่ค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าคิดว่าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยทำอาหารเก่งนะคะอ่าเพราะว่าครูฟ้าก็
อาจจะมีมีการกระทะใช่ไมมีกระทะแล้วก็มี
ตะหลิวอ่าแล้วก็มีไฟนะคะแล้วก็ทำอาหาร
เนาะทำต้มยำกุ้งทำผัดไทยนี่ครูฟ้าทำอาหาร
เก่งใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าทำอาหารเก่งนะคะนักเรียน
อือือ่ะใช่ค่ะครูหญิงเคยกินอาหารที่ครู
ฟ้าทำอร่อยนะคะแต่ครูหญิงทำอาหารอาหารไม่
เก่งไงอือ่าแต่ครูฟ้าแต่ว่าคิดว่าทำได้อื
ก็เก่งค่ะคือถ้าเราทำได้แล้วทำได้ดีก็
เก่งอคือพอครูฟ้าพูดถึงอาหารเนี่ยนะคะมัน
ก็เลยแบบว่าทำให้ครูหญิงเนี่ยคิดออก 1
อย่างครูหญิงอาจจะทำต้มยำกุ้งทำผัดไทย
เนี่ยไม่เก่งไม่อร่อยแตุ่หญิงทำ 1 เมนู
เก่งมีคนบอกว่าครูหญิงทำเมนูนี้เก่งมาก
อะไรคะครูหญิงครูหญิงทำเมนูนี้อะไรเก่ง
น้ำซีฟู้ดค่ะคิดว่าครูฟ้าก็ทำเก่งอ่าก็
คือแบบว่านักเรียนคะไหน
เอิ่มจริงๆครูหญิงโอ๊ยนี่คือครกเหรอคะครู
ฟ้าคือเราต้องมีครกนะคะนักเรียนแล้วก็มี
สากแล้วก็มีพริกเนาะพริกแล้วก็มีกระเทียม
อืมีกระเทียมนะคะมีมะนาวเนาะแล้วก็เอาไป
ตำๆๆนะคะแล้วเราก็จะได้เป็นน้ำจิ้มใช่มย
น้ำจิ้มเนี่ยน้ำจิ้มซีฟู้ดเนี่ยก็จะเอา
ไว้จิ้มกุ้งเนาะ
ปู
อ่ากุ้งปูใช่อร่อยนะคะน้ำจิ้มซีฟู้ดนะคะ
นักเรียนครูฟ้าบอกเลยว่าคนไทยชอบมากครู
ฟ้าชอบน้ำจิ้มซีฟู้ดมากๆใช่ค่ะนักเรียน
ครูหญิงต้องขอเปิดรูปให้ดูแล้วกันนะคะ
เพราะว่าได้
อุ้ยเอ่อคือถ้านักเรียนไปกินตามร้านอาหาร
น่ะนักเรียนก็จะเห็นว่ามันจะเป็นสีแบบนี้
เนาะน้ำจิ้มซีฟู้ดนะคะแต่ครูหญิงเนี่ยชอบ
ใช้พริกพริกที่ครูหญิงจะใช้เนี่ยครูหญิง
จะใช้พริกสีเขียวเท่านั้นไงออพริกที่เป็น
สีเขียวครูหญิงไม่ใช้พริกสีแดงไงครูฟ้า
พริกสีเขียวคือที่ไทยมันจะมีพริกสีเขียว
ใช่ไมั้ยคะแล้วก็พริกสีแดงใช่ครูฟ้าก็ใช้
พริกสีเขียวเพริกสีแดงแบบเนี้ยครูหญิงไม่
ใช้นะครูหญิงใช้พริกสีเขียวคือน้ำจิ้ม
ซีฟู้ดของครูหญิงมันก็จะออกมาหน้าตาแบบ
นี้เหมือนแบบนี้เลยใช่ๆๆใช่ค่ะเนี่ยแหละ
ค่ะเราก็จะเอาไว้จิ้ม
อุ้ยปูกุ้งใช่มยกุ้งอื
ปูปลาหมึกนะคะนักเรียนเนี่ยน้ำจิ้มซีฟู้ด
เนี่ยนะค่ะออือน้ำจิ้มซีฟู้ดเพราะว่าครู
หญิงเนี่ยนะคะเป็นคนที่ตำพริกเก่งไงแข็ง
แรงเหรอแขนเนี่ยแข็งแรงเวลาตำใช่มั้มัน
ต้องมีครกแล้วก็มีสากนะคะเราก็ต้องตำๆๆ
แบบไม่หยุดอ่ะค่ะนักเรียนมันต้องมีเทคนิค
ในการตำถ้านักเรียนตำแบบอย่างเงี้ยไม่ได้
ไม่อร่อยนะคะมันต้องตำๆๆๆๆๆๆแบบนี้ครู
หญิงก็เลยคิดว่าเอออันนี้แหละครูหญิงเก่ง
ค่ะครูฟ้าฟ้าชอบน้ำจิ้มซีฟู้ดใช่ครูฟ้าก็
ทำได้ใช่ไหมยคือเรา 2 คนเป็นคนอยู่ติด
ทะเลไงคะชลบุรีเนี่ยมันมีทะเลเราก็เลยทำ
ได้แล้วครูฟ้ามีอะไรเก่งอีอีกมั้ย
เอิ่มมี
ค่ะอะไรคะครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะ
คะคิดว่าครูฟ้าพูดเก่งอืครูหญิงจะบอกว่า
ครูฟ้าพูดแล้วก็ต้องเป็นเล่าเรื่องเวลา
ที่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยอ่านใช่มั้ยอ่านหนังสือ
สมมุติครูฟ้าอ่านหนังสือเป็นฟิกชั่น
จบ 1 เล่มแล้วคุยว่าครูฟ้าครูฟ้าอ่านจบ
แล้วเล่านะครูฟ้าก็จะมีนี่แล้วก็พูดพูด
ใช่มั้ยครูฟ้าก็จะเล่าเล่าให้ครูหญิงฟัง
อย่างเงี้ยแล้วครูหญิงก็ฟังที่ครูฟ้า
เนี่ยเล่าเล่าเล่าเป็นเรื่องครูหิงรู้สึก
ว่าครูฟ้าเล่าเรื่องเก่งครูฟ้าก็คิดว่า
ครูฟ้าน่าจะเล่าเรื่อง
เก่งใช่ค่ะอืหรือว่าครูฟ้าดูหนังดูซีรีส์
ใช่มยคะแล้วครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่ดูแต่ครูหญิง
อยากฟังแล้วครูหญิงบอกฟ้าครูฟ้าเล่าเล่า
หนังอสมมุติสไปเดอร์แมนครูฟ้าดู
สไปเดอร์แมนใช่ไมยเล่าให้ครูหญิงฟังหน่อย
แล้วครูฟ้าก็เล่าเล่าเล่าอแล้วครูหญิงก็
ฟังครูหญิงคิดว่าอันนี้ทุกคนไม่เหมือนกัน
ครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่ได้บางทีมันจะคิดมันไม่
เป็นสเต็ปในหัวอ่ะมันเล่าไม่ได้อ่าแต่ครู
เนี่ยเล่าเรื่องเก่งนะคะพูดููให้คนฟัง
เนี่ยเก่งอืเคิดว่านะเนาะเนี่ยแหละค่ะก็
คือหมดะหมดะนะเพราะว่าเวลาก็หมดด้วยนะคะะ
กินเก่งอีกอย่างนึงแล้วกันนะคะอถ้าครูฟ้า
กินเก่งงั้นครูหญิงนอน
เก่งโอเคอเนี่ยแหละค่ะก็คือเป็นเรื่องที่
เรา 2 คนคิดว่าเราเก่งนะคะแล้วนักเรียนมี
อะไรเก่งก็คอมเมนต์ได้นะคะส่วดีโอนี้ครู
หญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนเจอกันใหม่วดีโอหน้า
นะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ